horror outside kabul airport after a
suicide bomber ripped through desperate
crowds
horrific too for british troops on the
other side of the gate who rushed
forwards to help
their commander recalled the moment the
blast went off in the midst of british
and american efforts to evacuate
thousands of people
that's carnage
when that level of explosion
and combination of shrapnel
is detonated there is only one result
and that is carnage
brigadier james martin was in charge of
british ground troops on the evacuation
mission
the officer said their reaction to the
bombing was one of the finest things
he'd ever seen they ran towards the
explosion
they provided immediate medical sucker
and support to the afghan civilians that
had been wounded they provided explosive
ordnance disposal support to the
americans and they provided a security
perimeter so that the americans could
withdraw their wounded and their killed
with dignity
and under a screen of safety
13 u.s service personnel were killed and
more than a hundred afghans
but it could have been much worse and
the commander said it was largely
serendipity british forces didn't die
too
the night before we had done a clearance
operation because we knew there was a
threat out there in order to prove to
provide greater standoff between a
potential vector from a suicide bomber
and where we were dealing with the
crowds of evacuees and our own soldiers
and i think i think it's fair to say as
a result of that you know lives
absolutely were saved
the brigadier said soldiers had shed
tears because of what they saw during
the two-week evacuation
scenes like this witnessed by sky news's
stuart ramsey with children struggling
in the heat all the while british troops
having to work with the taliban a former
foe now this country's new rulers
there was emotions all the way through
the operations you can't see
a young
child a baby a woman crushed to death in
front of you
and then you having to deal with the
aftermath of that and the corpse or
provide medical attention to a baby
that's been struck by a five millimeter
ball bearing
you can't see any of that without being
emotional
emotional two no doubt when the final
troops left afghanistan last week after
evacuating more than fifteen thousand
people
courage and compassion even as their
twenty year war ended in retreat
debra haynes sky news